parfois en faisant des excavations on
découvre des corps de personnes
inconnues décédées depuis longtemps
comment les identifier
la génétique pourrait apporter la
réponse c'est l'automne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
au centre-ville de montréal on creuse on
réaménage des aqueducs ici le président
rencontre le passé les archéologues
exhument un corps
le square dorchester ce serait encore
plus de cinquante mille corps comme
celui ci c'est le site un des premiers
cimetière montréalais le cimetière
saint-antoine il a desservi la ville
entre 1799 et 1854
à qui appartient ce corps personne le
sait il a été enterré sans pierres
tombales sans nom comme il en était
coutume jusqu'à la moitié du 19e siècle
des généticiens ont trouvé le moyen
d'identifier certains de ces ossements
c'est unique de parvenir à révéler une
partie du secret history du québec
en découvrant l'identité de ces gens qui
sont restés anonymes jusqu'à aujourd'hui
plus important encore en faisant ça les
chercheurs sont en train de révéler le
portrait génétique des ancêtres des
québécois notre histoire génétique
on va probablement être au québec la
population d'un monde qui connaît le
mieux sa génétique de façon extensif
depuis sa fondation
[Musique]
il se retrouve ici dans ce laboratoire
de l'université de montréal
des ossements issus des premiers
cimetière montréal est exhumée lors de
divers travaux municipaux puis étudié
par isabelle ribot ce sont les premières
populations venues d'europe qui sont se
sont installés ici des centaines de
boîtes contenant des ossements d'anciens
québécois tous sans exception
anonyme sans arrêt on s'interroge sur
leur identité
retrouver leur identité
c'est le projet un peu fou de tommy
harding alors post doctorants on voulait
tester si on pouvait utiliser le pouvoir
en arrière de la généalogie de la
population du québec pour identifier
ville sépulture anonyme
cette idée est possible au québec parce
qu'il existe un registre exceptionnel ce
type de base de données généalogiques
populationnelle là on peut les compter
sur les doigts de la main dans le monde
[Musique]
balzac créé dans les années 70 documente
la quasi totalité de la population
québécoise française depuis le début du
peuplement européen jusqu'en 1965 le
québec
c'est ce qu'on appelle une population
fondatrice et fonde une population 9 mai
c'est une population qu'on peut
redresser à partir des débuts balzac
contient les données des registres
québécois actes de naissance de mariage
de décès des millions page
méticuleusement consignés par l'église
catholique ces actes ont permis de
recréer l'arbre généalogique des
québécois sur quatre siècles
l'identité des ossements se retrouvent
donc fort probablement quelque part dans
balzac mais comment on arrivait un an
grâce à la génétique
premièrement la base il nous faut une
référence contemporaine il faut le
profil génétique de des québécois qui
vivent aujourd'hui
ça tombe bien c'est un travail qu'avait
entrepris hélène vézina avec des
généticiens il ya plus de vingt ans ils
ont séquencé le génome de 950 québécois
contemporaine et recueillie le nom de
leurs parents grands parents ce qui
permet de les lier aux grands arbres
généalogiques à balzac l' indice le plus
important c'est l'adn mitochondrial un
héritage génétique transmis presque sans
modification de la mère à ses enfants et
une partie du chromosome y transmis de
père en fils ainsi avec cette
information génétique des québécois
moderne on peut remonter le temps et
déduire une partie du génome de leurs
ancêtres et alors à qui appartient les
ossements pour le savoir il reste à
comparer le matériel génétique des
ossements un homme avec un adn
mitochondrial est un chromosome y est
recherché dans balzac les individus
possédant des séquences identique et
pour un squelette
l'idée a fonctionné alors on a surtout
ce que l'adq crânien son nom de code 20
à es12
bon c'est pas grand-chose ans et moins
de 10% du squelette
vraisemblablement un homme dans la
cinquantaine retrouver avec un reste le
cercueil en bois dans balzac
tommy a identifié trois cent soixante
dix neuf individus avec les mêmes
marqueurs génétiques que ceux des
ossements est mort dans la période
d'exploitation du cimetière
on a donc remonté l'avenue maternelle de
s'auto l'un est selon les registres
un seul est enterré au cimetière
saint-antoine le un moment donné un
couple qui s'est marié à pierrefonds en
1713 qui ont eu un fils qui lui a été
enterré dans la paroisse notre dame
un homme né à pierre fin en 1775 mari en
1803 saint-eustache est mort à 58 ans
mais il reste beaucoup d'incertitudes
sur cette identification entre autres
parce qu on a l'information génétique
que d'une fraction des individus
recensés dans balzac évidemment là il
faut obtenir plus de données génétiques
pour avoir une
une confiance plus grand dans cette
identification le mais à la base je
crois que c'est très prometteur pour
l'avenir mais dévoilé la génétique d'un
individu si aussi révélé celle de sa
descendance c'est comprendre l'histoire
génétique des québécois de leurs traits
de leur maladie c'est une ouverture vers
une manne d'informations vraiment
intéressant surtout si on arrive à la
lui lié à d'autres types d'informations
généalogique des informations génétiques
sur la population actuelle le projet de
tommy harding et le coup d'envoi pour la
création d'un laboratoire de traitement
la dn ans il à l'université du québec à
trois rivières
l'idée c'est de générer de l'information
à partir d'un maximum de restes de
différentes époques pour créer une bio
bagdad et un ancien crée aussi des
données génétiques sur ces gens l'or est
ensuite sur
vertige de la population québécoise dans
le passé
au cours des prochaines années il sera
possible de mettre des noms sur de plus
en plus de sépulture car balzac sera
bientôt enrichi de milliers de nouveaux
profils génétiques
grâce à carthagène la base de données
biologiques québécoise ce n'est pas tout
balzac croît plus rapidement que jamais
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle pour
numériser automatiquement les registres
manuscrits balzac comprend la totalité
des actes de mariage passé mais il reste
encore à informatiser des millions
d'actes de naissance et de décès c'est
vraiment impressionnant
on va entrer plus de données en fichiers
balzac en trois ans qu'ils en aient eu
d'entrée en 50 ans donc
mais c'est tout un défi aussi ensemble
balzac carthagène et la biobanque da dn
anciens brosse en particulier pour la
population d'origine française
un portrait détaillé de leur histoire et
de leur génétique
le québec est en train de devenir un
terrain de recherche unique au monde
les données du québec sont peut-être les
plus extraordinaires qui soit
parce qu'on à cette profondeur temporel
et et cette couverture de l'histoire qui
est très grave avec beaucoup de sources
de données qu'on peut mettre ensemble
pour moi c'est une des populations qui
va nous aider à étudier
qu'est ce qui sépare ceux qui continuent
à se passer au plein de l'évolution
humaine
après ce séjour en université bientôt
les ossements seront ré inhumé ici au
cimetière notre dame des neiges à
montréal où il reposera en paix
[Musique]